ROBERT KUBIS: Have you ever
set up or managed a distributed
database and are tired of
the operational headache?
Or, are you considering moving
to one for scalability and high
availability reasons?
Oftentimes, you have to
choose between scalability
and consistency.
But also, ease of
setup and manageability
are important
factors to consider.
Hi, I'm Robert Kubis.
And in this video
series, we talk
about Google Cloud Spanner,
a fully managed relational
database service.
So do you want to
know how to provision
and scale a mission
critical database in seconds
without having to worry about
consistency or maintenance
windows?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When you hear about
Cloud Spanner,
many things feel and
sound like magic.
A database that is horizontally
scalable while offering
strong consistency across zones,
regions, or even globally--
how is this possible?
Before we look into some of
the details and technologies
how Cloud Spanner works, let
us get your own instance up
and running first.
In the Google Cloud
Console, search for Spanner.
Click on Create
Instance, and you'll
find all you need to set up
your instance in one screen.
You just name the instance.
Select the configuration
and how many nodes you want.
Done.
That was easy, right?
But wait.
What just happened?
Let's take a moment
here and talk
about which
configuration to choose
and how many nodes to select.
In Cloud Spanner,
compute nodes and storage
are separated to enable
scaling each independently.
On top, new nodes and
data are replicated
across multiple zones,
or even regions,
for higher availability.
When choosing a
configuration, you
have the option between
a regional instance
in a particular location
or a multi-region instance.
Let's drill down a
bit further there.
In a regional configuration,
your instance, compute,
and storage gets
distributed and replicated
across three zones
within one region--
for instance, your rest
or your essential one--
making sure your data stays
available and consistent
across hardware maintenance,
software patches,
or even failure
of an entire zone.
But what if you need
higher availability
guarantees and a
better read performance
from different places?
In that case, you
can choose one of
our multi-regional
configurations, which
distributes your instance
to up to four regions
across the globe.
This allows for an entire
region to become available,
while your database still
works as normal from all
the other regions.
Having your data available
in more than one region also
enables faster reads
from those regions.
And the best of all?
You don't have to worry about
setting up your own replication
or failure instances.
All this is fully managed
for you in one setting.
Now, what about nodes?
For each node you request
for your instance,
you get compute resources
in all zones and regions,
depending on your
selected configuration.
There's no need for difficult
planning, and forecasting,
and how many resources
to provision upfront.
You can just change the number
of instance nodes any time
you need more or fewer.
You just click on Edit Instance,
change the number of nodes,
and done.
Really easy.
And if you like your keyboard
more than your pointing device,
you can do all this
from the command line
as well, or with
our client libraries
that are available in
many, many languages.
Your instance is
now up and running.
Actually, it has been
ready and waiting for us
since we clicked that
little Create button.
So let's go ahead and create
a database and schema.
It's recommended to do
both at the same time.
Schemas in Cloud
Spanner are just
like any other
relational database.
You have tables and columns
that are strongly typed.
And if you need to
add a table, or index,
or remove a column
in the future,
you can just do so without
any downtime incurred.
Cloud spanner runs
schema changes
in a long-running transaction.
But keep in mind, depending
on individual statements
that you execute
for schema changes,
they can range from
minutes for adding
a column to hours
for backfilling
an index on a large database.
Now that your
database is created,
you can use our client libraries
to write and read data.
Cloud Spanner also
speaks SQL, which
lets you reuse and
test your existing
skills of working with
traditional relational
databases.
The next step is to look
into loading some data
and how to do this efficiently.
Unfortunately, we are out
of time in this episode,
and we will keep that
for the next one.
So if you want to learn
more about Cloud Spanner
best practices and
inner workings,
follow this featured
series and check out
the links in the description.
In the next episode of
"Things-I-Learned about Cloud
Spanner," we will look at how
to pick the right primary keys
to enable fast and
efficient writes and reads.
And remember, you don't need
to sacrifice consistency
for scalability.
[MUSIC PLAYING]